et une vidéo fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux depuis ce matin et indign on y
entend plusieurs personnes antoné un
champ antisémite dans le métro parisien
en cœur avec de nombreux passagers qui
semble sourire de la situation Manon qui
a filmé cette fameuse vidéo est avec
nous ce soir il va tout nous expliquer
c'est fou parce que Manon aujourd'hui
tout le monde ne parlait que d'elle
cette personne qu'on voit et c'est vrai
que sur les réseaux on dit oui pourquoi
elle rigole et cetera elle voudrait
s'expliquer aussi ce soir Manon regardez
des images si vous n'avez pas vu ces
images sachez que c'était dans le métro
parisien aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est
c'est aujourd'hui c'était aujourd'hui
dans le métro parisien g hier soir sur
la lig
li c'est l'actualité du jour
[Musique]
regardez Grand
Est
[Musique]
incroyable cette vidéo alors nous avons
récupérer une seconde vidéo filmée
visiblement cette fois-ci par un des
jeunes en train de chanter le même
groupe de jeunes
regardez
[Applaudissements]
93ouou vive le 93 ouais vive la C
ouais
[Applaudissements]
ou ou a ouais ça ouais
oua oua voilà donc c'est ce même groupe
de garçons Manon merci d'être avec nous
B merci à vous vraiment c'est c'est fou
d'avoir filmé ça aujourd'hui quand on va
on va revenir sur toute l'histoire mais
quand vous avez filmé vous êtes dit quoi
vous êtes dit c'est c'est je suis je
suis dans un monde de fou vous êtes dit
quo bah honnêtement je savais pas trop
ce qui se passait ouais je rentrais
juste des cours et bah j'ai vu une bande
de jeunes pour moi il c'estit quasiment
20 arrivé dans le métro comme des
sauvages je me suis dit ou là ils vont
caer le métro et je m'attendais pas du
tout à ce que ils sortent des des propos
de la comme ça quoi enfin c'est super
grave PZ raconter depuis le début donc
ce qui se passe il est quelle heure là
il était 18h20 à peu près 18h20 donc
vous êtes dans le métro tranquille et
quand vous les avez vu arriver vous avez
vous avez flippé un peu c'est ça j'ai
flippé je me suis dit mais enfin ils
sont quand même énormes enfin c'est ils
sont combien combien pour moi ils
étaient quasiment une vingtaine je pense
ils sont vraiment arrivés en masse en
tapant contre les vites du métro bah
vraiment comme des sauvages je me suis
dit voou là on va se faire prendre à
parti et vraiment je m'attendais pas ils
ont commencé en fait à à chanter direct
oui ils ont commencé bah déjà à faire
énormément de Boucan et ils ont commencé
déjà à insulter donc la police oui
d'accord ils ont ils ont insulté la
police nique la bag que nique la police
mais en boucle en fait d'accord ils ont
aussi insulté la France en lesant nique
la France et cetera mais vive la CAF
c'est ça oui oui oui oui exactement ils
ont dit aussi vive le
RSA c'est ça ils ont aussi insulté la
communauté LGBT en disant oui nique la
communauté LGBT vous aurezti contre la
police contre la communauté LGBT contre
la France ça c'est ça et contre aussi le
peuple juif donc c'est en ce moment en
fait où j'ai filmé savaiit pas du tout
en fait ce qu'ils allaient dire moi j'ai
commencé peur de filmer ils vous
voyaient ou pas du tout non ils étaient
ils étaient vraiment dans leur truc j'ai
quand même essayer de de de me cacher un
peu parce que j'avais un peu peur qu'on
qu'on me prenne mon téléphone ou qu'on
prenne la partie mais je voulais
vraiment que ces proposlà soi
euh diffusé entre guillemets pour pour
que les gens voient ce qui s'est passé
dans le métro parce que si j'avais pas
filmé bah personne l'aurait vu je trouve
ça très très très très grave ce genre de
propos mais c'est c'est extrêmement
grave qu'est-ce quelle a été la réaction
des des autres passagers dans le métro
euh ils étaient tous scandalisés euh ils
savaient pas trop comment réagir il y a
une dame qui a essayé de de leur dire
non par contre pas les Juifs et ben ils
se sont moqué d'elle ils l' envoyé
boulet et et quand ils ont n nique la
France il y a un vieux monsieur qui leur
a dit mais pourquoi vous restez en
France dans ces cas-là si vous insultez
il a dit bah nous on est juste logé en
fait on est logé vive le rsa ni la
France et vive la CAF donc ilétait une
vingtaine vingtaine de jeunes euh ils
sont restés combien de temps dans le
dans le wagon avec vous j'aurais dit
plutôt une dizaine de minutes ils sont
descendus à Opéra d'accord euh donc ça a
duré plusieurs stations mais c'était
vraiment station à peu près je saurais
pas trop trop dire j'étais vraiment sous
le coup sous le coup euh cé interminable
bah c'est ça surtout je comprenais pas
forcément pas pens à sortir du du métro
non vous bah j'étais j'étais assise et
j'ai juste B je je filmais je me suis
dit vaut mieux que les propos soi quand
même enregistrés parce que c'est très
très grave euh c'est c'est c'est
incroyable oui non mais il y a une
libération de la parole antisémite qui
est insupportable je sais même pas si on
aurait pu tenir ses propos il y a il y a
il y a il y a quelques semaines enc
homophobe tout he en France tout juste
j'aimerais qu'on vienne sur les faits je
vous dis à 21h30 on est vraiment sur les
fait il sont pas sur Gilles est-ce que
de votre point de vue quand ils sont
entrés dans le métro ils avaient déjà ce
champ ces champs très violents mais
notamment celui contre les Juifs en tête
c'était leur but de choquer ou c'était
plutôt si je puis dire une bande de
jeunes comme ça qui est entré qui a
voulu semer la pagaille B je pense
qu'ils ont juste voulu amuser la galerie
et euh enfin c'était vraiment pour moi
c'était des collégiens et euh c'était
juste pour amuser la galerie faire les
clown se marrer quoi a pas eu
d'agressivité envers aucun passager non
non non c'était juste ils étaient là il
faisaient bouger la RAM il taper sur les
sur les les parois du métro c'était
juste pour [__] entre guillemets le
bordel alors Manon certains sont
indignés de vous voir rigoler dans la
dans la vidéo voulez faire une mise au
point à ce sujet je crois aussi oui j'ai
déjà essayé de répondre à plusieurs
commentairire donc en fait effectivement
donc je ris sur la vidéo mais c'était
vraiment un rire de nerveux parce que
bah je savais pas trop comment réagir
j'étais vraiment scandalisé c'était
totalement inattendu moi je voulais
juste rentrer chez moi là base j'
rentrais des cours j'étais fatiguée et
je m'attendais pas du tout à entendre
bah de tels propos dans le métro donc
c'était vraiment juste j'étais j'étais
j'étais choquée c'était pas du tout
ou un rire comme certains peuvent
l'interpréter un rire qui cautionne ses
propos c'est ça ou qui voilà ou c'est ça
donc j'ai quand même dit en légende de
la vidéo comme quoi je ne cautionnais
absolument pas les propos qui ont été
tenus vous avez compris tout de suite ce
qu'il disait parce qu'on va revoir la
vidéo et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
compliqué à rentendre moi j'ai dû
l'entendre plusieurs fois
réécouter
la PAL ouais la Paltinis
ouais les
grand grandm on est des naz on est
[Musique]
F alors ils avaient quel âge c'est jeun
pour moi c'était ça dev des collégiens
je pense parce qu'était vraiment très
très jeune oui vraiment genre voilà 14
15 ans oui à peu près alors quand ils
sont parce qu' on se pose plein de
questions et tous les téléspectateurs se
posent plein de questions personne ne
s'interposer juste des petites des
personnes qui s'indignent un peu mais
personne ne s'interposer personne n'a
n'a voulu arrêter ça cétait tout le
monde était un peu tétanisé non c'est ça
bah il y en a quand même qui ont essayé
bah la la jeune femme et le et le vieux
monsieur mais contre une bande de de bah
de 20 de 20 jeunes on se dit enfin on
sait pas trop ce qu'ils ont sur eux
s'ils ont un couteau si donc on est là
on est un peu enfin ça quand même c'est
compliqué de bah d'intervenir dans cette
situation là vous avez vous avez décidé
de mettre la vidéo tout de suite sur les
réseaux non j'ai quand même réfléchi
j'ai quand même réfléchi puis je me suis
dit que fallait quand même que ces
propos là soient rapportés rapportés
c'est ça que les gens puissent voir ce
qui s'est passé dans le métro par c'est
très très graveè bravo Manon parce que
c'est très important ce que vous avez
fait parce que sans vous on a'aurait pas
vu ça alors que c'était c'est quelque
chose s'est passé hier soir aux alentour
de 18h c'est c'est complètement fou oui
g la grande question qu'on se pose dans
ces cas-là c'est on est dans le métro
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et c'est vrai que
je je vous le dis avec énormément de
respect mais ça ça étonne que personne
n'it tiré le signal d'alarme soit sorti
prévenir le conducteur pour arrêter la
rame pour pouvoir les interpeller voyez
personne n'a eu attention je dis pas que
je leuris fait du tout hein mais
personne n'a eu cette idée là de de
d'agir promptement non je pense qu'on
était vraiment tous tous choqués par par
ce qui est se passait on réalisait pas
forcément bah l'ampleur de la chose
vousêes pas dit ça plus loin ils vont
ils vont ils vont s'en prendre à nous
passagers de de RAM bah au début c'était
justement ma crainte quand ils ont
commencé à rentrer dans la rame on a
l'impression que limite vous ê êtes
soulagé excusez-moi de dire ça mais
limite vous êtes dit bon ils sont venus
faire des des guignoles c'est ça bah au
début je me suis Mo ilst des barres de
fer ils vont rentrer ça va être comme
les émeutes donc j'avoue j'ai eu un
petit peu peur sur le coup mais au vu
des des propos tenus c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas moins grave on va dire B oui
JAAC moi je trouve que mademoiselle vous
avez un courage parce que on sait que
ces momentsl ça peut al là on les
connaît pas on les voit pas et vous nous
dites que c'est vous nous apprenez que
ce sont des collégiens mais ça peut
aussi mal tourner si les gens réagissent
donc je suis pas tellement d'accord avec
toi Gilles je trouve qu'il y a pas de
polémique à avoir là-dessus je trouve
que vous êtes une lanceur d'alerte
lanceuse d'alerte et que alors il faut
signaler qu'il y a la plateforme Faros
c'estàdire que oui mais c'est c'est
important pour les gens qui veulent pas
forcément êt sur les réseaux mais mais
je trouve queelle a elle a elle a du
courage deire et et de le signaler parce
que sont des propos qui sont évidemment
inadmissibles qui doivent pas être tenus
c'est pas une question seulement
d'antisémitisme c'est c'est l'impression
d'un grand magma de grand mais là
justement on en est où Gill Verdes de
l'enquête là-dessus sur ces personnes
alors c'est remonté jusquau on peut les
identifier partoutou oui c'est remonté
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'État donc
il y a une enquête qui a été déclenchée
tout de suite confié au service régional
des transports avec tous les moyens
toutes les vidéos sur ance de toutes les
stations de métro de toutes les rames je
suppose que vous allezêt solliciter
aussi peut-être l'avez-vous déjà été par
la police ils vont tout faire pour les
identif sûr qu' vont les retrouver très
vite même avec le leur compte insta et
cetera c'est finis vite normalement
c'est ce soir ils sont ils sont des oui
mais alors pourquoi la vidéosurveillance
est importante parce que quand il y a un
phénomène de groupe comme ça c'est qui a
prononcé cette parole là pour pouvoir
les les choper et après éventuellement
les condamner donc c'est très important
là ce soir là ils étaient en cours
d'identification ils n'ont pas encore
été interpellés et ils risquent très
très gros Cyril même s'ils sont mineurs
parce que il y a la phrase notamment on
est des nazis et fiers qui pourrai après
être qualifi d'apologie du terrorisme et
qui pourrait valoir an de prisons alors
c'est des mineurs se seraient divisés
s'ils étaient condamnés he par deux P
c'est vraiment qu'ils vont
faire vont être
condamnés je pens qu'ils vont rien faire
ils vont peut-être être convoqués moi je
pense qu'il faut convoquer les parents
du coup pour savoir que c'est même pas
l'éducation là je crois pas la ce là
directement ah non non mais là l'émotion
est nationale
non il
ê raison attendons de voir je suis
d'accord avec Rapp à la loi non mais
pens un rappel à la loi vous ce qui va
arver ils vont dire que c'est des gamins
et que Ctait que c'est des gamins qui
sont rentrés dans le métro qu'ils ont
chanté qu' y en a un qui a lancé l'ut a
suivi des qui tomb s le coup de la loi
quand ils sont partis Manon s'il vous
plaît quand ils sont partis vous êtes
dit quoi ceux qui rest dans dans le dans
la j'essayer de réaliser en fait on
s'est tous regardé on était on était
choqué on essay juste de bah de réaliser
ce qui s'est passé en fait vous avez
parlé entre vous pas du tout même pas
pas du tout personne ne sait parler
après de ce qui venait se passer
personne non le silence silence limite
soulagé qui soit parti quoi c'est ça
exactement tout le monde était soulagé
parce que ça a duré combien de temps dit
bonne dizaine de minutes c'est très long
c'est très très long ils ont chanté tout
le long oui tout le long et et en criant
il y avait des gens qui rentraient ou
qui voul qui n'osaient plus rentrer il
pouvit pas il pouvaient pas pouvait pas
rentrer dans la rame c'était pas
possible ils étaient vraiment devant les
portes en fait ils étaient vraiment bah
dans le métro il c'était vraiment entre
les deux portes donc personne pouvait
rentrer personne pouvait sortir en fait
fallait vraiment sortir par une autre
porte ou rentrer par une autre porte et
puis quand ils sont sortis ils ont
failli bousculer un vieux monsieur aussi
ils sont vraiment sortis bah comme tues
sauvagess sont descendus à quelle
station à Opéra à Opéra d'accord ce que
vous nous avez dit donc à Opéra ils sont
descendus derrière à Opéra c'est vrai
que c'est c'est complètement fou de voir
ça aujourd'hui c'est vrai que derrière
ils ont pu partir tranquillement oui
c'est ça qui est complèt oui puis plutôt
fier d'eux visiblement enfin content
d'eux ça mais en plus ils ont commenté
le TikTok ils ont commencé mon ils ont
commenté mon TikTok qu's ont dit en
disant ouais c'est nous on est
fier enfin et et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a réussi à avoir le le compte
TikTok d'un des d'un des garçons qui a
du coup bah posté le TikTok qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure et et vraiment ils
avaient l'air d'être très très fier et
je pense que le pire aussi dedans c'est
qu'il y avait énormément de personnes en
fait qui cautionnaient les propos qu'ils
ont tenu en disant oui ils ont raison
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai qu'on voit
des personnes dans votre vidéo limite
rigoler vraiment et dire ouais c'était
un genre c'était marrant quoi ouais
c'est ça ouai c'est exactement ça c'est
fou ça ce que vous nous dites parce que
vous n dites ouais il y avait des gens
qui disaient ouais c'est c'est plutôt
ils ont raison dans ce qu'ils disent
c'est ça donc après bon euh il y avait
des gens qui venaient qui venaient
répondre à leurs commentaires en en les
incendiant entre guillemets mais euh moi
je sais qu'on était quand même on a
quand même été jusqu'à me chercher mon
insta mon Link kedine pour m'envoyer des
des insuls UL oui tu as pas honte de
rigoler comme ça tu es la honte de la
France en m'insultant de pauvr Conn et
cetera ENF est-ce qu'il y avait des gens
qui vous ont aussi insulté ou un des
groupes qui vous ont dit pourquoi vous
avez filmé et cetera ou il était plutôt
fier il y a il y a quand même un des
garçons donc après avoir dit oh c'est
nous c'est nous c'est nous qui du coup a
fait un commentaire en me disant comme
quoi il m'avait demandé de supprimer la
vidéo chose qu'ils n'ont jamais fait ils
m'ont jamais contacté il m'a dit qu'il
voulait porter plante pour droit à
l'image et je leur ai dit mais on vous
voit pas justement j'ai fait exprès vous
êtes de dos enfin on vous voit pas c'est
juste toi qui qui a dit oui c'est nous
enfin tu t'es toi-même identifié moi je
j'ai rien fait j'ai juste posté les
propos j'ai pas incroyable et et donc
ils se sont prêt à vous il y en a qu'un
qui vous a contacté aucun des autres non
juste un alors sachez qu'il y a déjà il
y aurait déjà des gardes à vu hein ça y
est déjà depuis depuis aujourd'hui euh
concernant ce petit groupe façon quand
ils vont retrouvver un ils vont tous
retrouver très très vite après comme a
dit géraline on va voir
ce qui va se passer vous allez reprendre
le métro très vite ou vous êtes
traumatisé quand même parce un événement
comme ça c'est ça pe j'avoue que je suis
un peu traumatisée parce que je la ligne
3 c'est quand même une ligne de métro où
il y a pas forcément énormément de
problèmes dessus on va dire c'est une
ligne plutôt calme et là le fait de voir
ça débarquer grand groupe honnêtement ça
traumatise un peu donc
ouais c'est sûr c'est c'est extrêmement
tratisant et ça va être un peu compliqué
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
bah merci à vous merci beaucoup tout de
suite c'est mon je ville sur ces H8
merci